c'est le sujet qui déchaîne les réseaux
il y a plusieurs plusieurs millions de
vues sur l'aventure d'un homme que l'on
croyait être un homme à femme que l'on
croyait être en fait plus le bourreau
que la victime et pourtant c'est vous
mesdames messieurs non je parle de gens
mais non
des millions de vues absolument alors je
vais vous dire que vous avez raconté
à l'émission vous avez préféré le faire
ailleurs
je vous laisse l'entière responsabilité
de votre comportement mais ça fait des
millions de vues je sais pas si je vous
le dis donc on va regarder un petit
récap sur Jean-Michel maire qui est donc
fait un témoignage ailleurs
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
alors qu'il a sorti un nouvel ouvrage où
il déclaraitre un looser heureux
Jean-Michel maire fait souvent face à
des histoires incroyables il y a
quelques semaines sur notre plateau le
journaliste avait raconté ses déboires
amoureux en déclarant cette refait
arnaquée par une femme après un
rendez-vous il manquait un tableau mon
iPad et une montre et cette semaine le
chroniqueur emblématique de TPMP était
invité sur France 2 où il a fermé que
son ex-compagne lui montait et lui avait
vidé son compte en banque pendant un an
et demi je suis à grenaille
je fais confiance un témoignage choc qui
a touché de nombreux téléspectateurs
alors que s'est-il passé pour
Jean-Michel maire victime d'une arnaque
à l'amour retour sur l'incroyable
témoignage de Jean-Michel ce soir dans
TPMP
[Musique]
et le témoignage de Jean-Michel maire a
ému des milliers de personnes et les
vidéos comptent plusieurs millions de
vues alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je
veux tout savoir
déjà vous êtes un peu comme moi parce
que quelqu'un qui vous pompe votre
compte en banque pendant un an et demi
sans qu'on se rend compte soit il est
extrêmement garni non c'est parce que je
suis très négligeant c'est j'ouvre j'ai
une phobie il nous faut bien
administrative comme un ancien ministre
et je n'ouvre pas mon courrier je
réponds pas aux appels des banquiers etc
donc peut-être qu'ils ont essayé de
m'avertir en tout cas je n'ai rien vu
sur mes comptes parce que je ne regarde
pas mes comptes je me dis que ton tant
qu'il y en a encore un peu voilà je peux
m'accarter
comme ça parce qu'en fait pour résumer
je suis resté pendant un an et demi avec
une femme que je croyais bien connaître
parce qu'elle habitait chez moi avec sa
fille voilà que que j'adorais que je
considérais un peu comme ma propre fille
paradoption et je me suis rendu compte
ma au final au bout d'un an et demi que
qu'elle met elle m'avait menti sur son
prénom sur sa sur son âge surtout sur
ses parents sur son ex-mari sur sa fille
surtout je pense qu'on en a un an et
demi il y a pas une chose de vrai dans
ce que je savais sur elle tout s'écroulé
du jour au lendemain justement la suite
à l'appel d'un banquier alors là parce
que on connaît ces histoires qui c'est
arrivé à beaucoup de gens en fait d'être
avec une personne qu'on ne connaît pas
du tout en dehors du fait du préjudice
financier moralement c'est très
compliqué de se rendre compte qu'on a
vécu avec quelqu'un qu'on a du mal ça
aurait pu mal se terminer parce que il y
a même aucune aucune possibilité de la
retrouver parce que tout ce que je
savais sur elle était faux donc même si
j'avais voulu à la recherche d'ailleurs
j'ai perdu de vue je sais même pas où
est-ce qu'elle est mais peu importe
j'espère qu'elle est heureuse là où elle
y a aucun souci avec ça voilà mais
non j'ai pas déposé plainte parce que
déjà elle avait pas d'argent voilà quand
je l'ai connu elle était elle vivait
chichement elle avait sa fille à charge
etc c'était déjà compliqué pour elle
donc j'allais pas en plus l'enfoncer la
tête sous l'eau je me suis fait arnaquer
tant pis pour moi c'est voilà c'est mais
c'est pas le préjudice financier qui est
le plus important
compris aussi monter
à me mentir pour justifier laver une
dizaine d'années 8 aucun moment parce
que c'est comme c'est un talent quand
même d'arriver à faire
elle aurait dû faire le cinéma
absolu quand même hein
justement mais non mais parce que elle
sait jamais trahie les gens me disent
mais comment t'as pas
tu voyais pas ses amis
en gros elle était me racontait qu'elle
avait été abusé par son père quand elle
était jeune qu'elle avait tué son père
mais personne ne le savait d'ailleurs
quand elle quand j'ai voulu à la fin
rompre et dans son histoire elle me dit
mais non mais je te promets que je vais
arrêter tous mes mensonges etc et
d'ailleurs je te fais une déclaration
d'aveu de d'humeur de mon père par écrit
comme ça tu peux t'en servir contre moi
le jour où vraiment tu veux mais en fait
il vivait avec une psychopathe
parce que l'amour que tu avais pour elle
a pris le dessus pour pas te rendre
compte
mon amour parce que je me disais avec
tout ce qu'elle a vécu d'être encore
aussi forte aujourd'hui comme comme le
dit la chanson et ben du coup ça
renforçait un peu le respect
l'admiration que j'avais d'elle en
disant comment on pète il restait aussi
positif après tous les drames qu'on a
vécu est-ce que tu as appris qu'elle
avait déjà arnaqué d'autres types avant
vous je sais pas parce que bon je
connaissais déjà pas cette vie actuelle
je me trompais donc sa vie d'avant je
savais que ce qu'elle me disait tout
était faux marié était mort sur
l'autoroute brûler vive que de son vous
l'avez été kidnappé par des cernes dans
un appartement
violée par un chauffeur de taxi elle est
sortie du taxi en route dans le bois de
Vincennes à 30 km
du 3e étage pour se suicider etc elle
t'a volé combien en somme d'argent je me
suis arrêté je me j'ai quand je l'ai
découvert le pot le le poteau rose j'ai
commencé à regarder mes comptes et je me
suis arrêté parce que je me suis dit un
moment ça me fait ça sert à rien de
compter jusqu'au bout je me serais à
17000 €
et moi quand je faisais confiance elle
avait mes codes etc parce que je disais
les cartes bleues vous donner le code
mais c'est qui pareil non j'ai pas de
chéquier on a plus beaucoup de checker
enfin je crois pas j'espère pas mais
à l'école elle prenait la carte bleue et
elle retirait tout ce qu'elle peut vous
distributeur et moi je comme je regarde
pas et bien mais ce qui est remettez la
carte de mon portefeuille après en
revenant de l'école et moi j'étais pas
levé encore et ce que je trouvais
bizarre c'est que à chaque fois que je
voulais me servir de ma carte bleue pour
acheter des cigarettes ou je ne sais
quoi à chaque fois on disait montant
dépassé je sais pas possible ma carte
bleue marche pas il me disent que je
l'ai passé je pensais jamais etc tu sais
pas gérer tes comptes tu es une merde je
m'en occupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ma tête en une seconde comme dans
les films les pièces du puzzle sur ça
sembler et là je me suis comme par
hasard
j'ai joué encore la comédie encore
quelques temps donc j'ai fait croire que
que
j'avais pas compris elle a fait semblant
d'aller à l'enterrement de sa mère etc
elle s'habille en noir avec la poêle est
tout elle est partie enterrement etc
du coup ça a duré du coup genre elle est
dans le coma on essaie de maintenir et
puis finalement les stars
que la mer n'est pas morte que elle
enlève du coup là j'ai enquêté j'ai
quitté
à ce projet elle invente un coma une
semaine machin du coup j'ai commencé
enquêter et j'ai trouvé sa sœur qui
habite en région parisienne que j'ai
rencontré et c'est elle qui du coup qui
m'a tout avoué en disant qu'elle est
dans la famille elle est connue elle est
brouillée un peu sa famille parce
qu'elle est complètement mythomane et
elle me dit quoi elle m'a elle m'a
démonté tout ce que je savais bah dès
que je disais elle s'appelle bien quand
même Victoria elle est bien libanaise
pas du tout
partir
j'ai voulu qu'on sépare à ce moment-là
elle ne voulait pas partir
elle a fini par t'avouer que c'était une
vraie mythomane ou pas
panique a été mythomane mais elle m'a
dit oui elle m'a fait croire un autre
mytho que avec son ancien mec elle était
battu du coup elle se oblige elle se
sentait obligé d'avoir de s'inventer une
vie pour se protéger là où vous auriez
dû quand même porter plainte c'est
personne pour besoin de d'un d'aide
parce que elle est collée elle est
malade
oui bien sûr bien sûr on peut pas donner
son nom mais je suis même pas sur le
vrai entre l'arnaque du CO2 et celle-là
tu as pas 20 balles est-ce qu'il est
marrant je l'ai quitté je sais plus quel
mois c'était au mois de mars avril un
truc comme ça et pendant plusieurs mois
après quand je passais dans la rue les
commerçants de tomber dessus il disait
monsieur maire faudra penser à nous
rembourser
votre fiancé venu est venu nous voir
elle avait noté et non parce qu'elle
disait genre cette petite amie de
Jean-Michel maire vous avez déjà vu
ensemble il est alité en ce moment il
est très malade sa carte bleue est
bloquée est-ce que vous pouvez me prêter
de l'argent pour arriver à faire etc et
donc dès que je passais dans la rue à
chaque fois un commerçant qui sortait
monsieur bien vous oubliez pas vous
devez 500 balles quand même oui je vais
voir
Michel alors ne bougez parce que je
pense qu'on va encore apprendre des
choses
hallucinante ne bougez pas tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retournons Touche pas
à mon poste weekend avec Casta tu as pas
encore été ça une nourriture avec
Jean-Michel maire qui nous racontait son
incroyable escroquerie qui a duré 1 an
et demi il a vécu avec une personne qui
ne connaissait pas qui lui avait inventé
un passé un présent et limite un futur
au passage elle vous a délesté de 17000
€ voir minimum oui mais je me suis
arrêté là et ce qui est fou c'est
qu'elle s'est quand même enféré dans son
mensonge le plus gros
les gens sont très forts c'est que je me
suis brouillé avec mes amis je me suis
brouillé avec mon meilleur ami quand je
vais raconter l'histoire du viol de son
père tout ça il m'a dit mais libre à toi
d'y croire ça m'avait choqué je me suis
dit comment ça tu me prends pour un
pigeon ou pas et du coup je me suis
fâché avec mon meilleur ami je n'ai plus
jamais revu depuis à cause d'elle donc
j'ai perdu pas que l'argent j'ai perdu
surtout un meilleur ami c'était plus
embêtant et voilà il est pas revenu
meilleur ami non c'est Gilles il m'a
proposé de me revoir et tout mais bon
quand leur sort est un peu détendu c'est
plus compliqué la question que tout le
monde se posait pourquoi ne pas avoir
porté plainte déjà financièrement je
comptais rien récupérer et je me suis
dit en plus
j'espère sincèrement qu'elle est
heureuse aujourd'hui quels sont les
sorties qu'elle a sorti la tête de l'eau
etc vu le profil
j'espère en tout cas et
juste avant au moment où je l'ai quand
même je la poussée pour qu'elle quitte
l'appartement quand même parce que ça
s'arrête et là elle m'a menacé quoi elle
a commencé par menacer quoi c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a été plus confondante d'excuses
ni rien là d'être venu menaçant et elle
m'a dit si si c'est une maladie parce
que c'est exactement ça en fait c'est
d'abord il y a la colère en plus après
les accusations c'est les mythomanes
c'est ça en fait c'est à dire que
d'abord il n'y est raconte leurs
histoires etc ensuite ils se mettent en
colère c'est toujours de ta faute c'est
à dire que c'est la faute de l'autre
enfin c'est un vrai truc moi je suis
déjà tombée aussi sur quelqu'un qui
était un peu enfin carrément mytho le
truc que tu devrais faire c'est diffuser
son portrait donc pour que les autres si
tu veux soit
toute
parce que quand je lui ai dit quand même
pour la forcer à partir j'ai dit je vais
quand même finir par appeler la police
raconter toute l'histoire et puis tu vas
peut-être finir par avoir des problèmes
elle me dit bah essaie de jouer à ça si
tu veux il dit bah demain matin c'était
simple c'est que je vais prendre un
objet je vais me donner un grand coup
sur la gueule je vais le commissariat je
veux dire que tu m'agresser sexuellement
tu m'as violenté tu me tu m'as violet
mais c'est déjà je me suis fait arnaquer
on peut faire de mon boulot je vais tout
faire le temps que la vérité éclate je
vais tout perdre et du coup après elle
m'a dit non je l'aurais jamais fait mais
tellement fait peur que du coup j'ai
dernière question Jean-Michel est-ce que
aujourd'hui dans vos nouvelles relations
ça a changé quelque chose que ça vous a
rendu non non non ah oui vous êtes
vraiment
trop gentil ouais non c'est pas une
question de gentillesse une question
quand je fais confiance j'aime bien
faire confiance entièrement et puis si
je suis trompé ou je trahi bah après
j'en tire les leçons mais c'est ça sera
encore pire que je me renferme sur moi
et que je fasse plus confiance aux gens
quoi tu pourrais écrire un livre ah bah
oui
film d'horreur et puis après quand j'ai
commencé à réfléchir j'ai eu d'autres
histoires comme ça on a fait un chapitre
disponible
sur Amazon merci Jean-Michel